oh you roll with guys like out of your
weight class oh yeah yeah uh what do you
think i only roll with heavyweights oh
[ __ ] i don't know
a problem with heavyweights it's hard to
find a good one yeah hard to find
training partners right
mm-hmm damn he had the biggest guys come
in these
[ __ ] dudes he'd be like that guy's
six nine what the [ __ ] we'd have to pay
him and should have sucked
oh really and then because it just you
said there wasn't a lot of heavy weights
so i'd always go with a lot of 205 which
i preferred because they're more
talented usually
faster got it oh okay that makes sense
oh smaller guys so it wasn't like
the smaller guy's always more talented
okay but they're trying to knock your
head off
that was what's crazy about some of that
stuff like his his coach uh his coach
offered this six nine he goes i'll give
you a thousand dollars if you can knock
him out
what so now brennan that guy needed the
money and you guys didn't even
warm up i was like yeah what's going on
here
you you i remember exactly what happened
you did this weird look
you did a stretch where you went like
that you did a lunge and you did this
and you did this
and then you did this and then
i was like what's going on and then
there you go and then
and then he went the guy went boom and
tried to hook you so hard and you just
went
you ducked just like this zoom and it
went thing
it kind of like gave you a haircut and
then you double leg them and you guys
cry it was so [ __ ] nuts it was
on and on like on on on that black house
trying to knock each other the [ __ ] out
you know so i remember when he came in
the room i looked at him and i went like
this my face
changed i went he's the biggest guy i've
ever seen in my life and he's got
cauliflower ears
he's six nine yeah six eight six six but
but like professional
mma professional kickboxer high level
and and and
brandon's getting his his things wrote
and he looked at me and he goes do you
want to be a fighter huh
and i went different kids it just
it just sounds so stressful it's an
awful way to make it so [ __ ] every
time you go exactly
[ __ ] knock a guy out your heart's
beating every tuesday
for real time but like so like when you
guys are like sparring and all that
stuff like you're going
like is if you're like during the fight
especially when you're close to the
fight
so you have to go that hard um yeah
typically
yeah if you guys are that hard you're
gonna be in for a big surprise in a real
fight
yeah because you're in a once they lock
their cage the guy's trying to kill you
and he's and he's 260 pounds so [ __ ]
intense
yes the one that once intense jump the
one crazy thing is i had my hand on the
cage
watching and they locked up
and crashed into my hand
500 pounds
it was a silent scream like you got
electrocuted
and my fingers i was like [ __ ] and then
they they bounced off that cage and went
over and landed both on their [ __ ]
heads and your neck was [ __ ] up
forever after that oh [ __ ] he almost
broke his neck
like he landed on his neck i was like
might be dead and then that [ __ ] me up
with a trash brown fight because the
exact same thing happened remember
ah cause you had to take him down
he sprawled in his hip that gave you the
concussion oh yeah
yeah yeah i [ __ ] my neck that's a good
time it's a great way to make a living
no so much fun man that's a tough case
no
so much fun you know about that guy and
if he doesn't if he loses then he goes
down the rankings and he doesn't eat
it's a great time us three sitting here
is a great
but the biggest the biggest thing i
remember the biggest thing you gotta
remember is heavyweights
heavyweights nobody ever talks about is
like if you're 170 140 155 pounds
you can afford to make mistakes you can
take shots you can slip you it's a
different way of fighting
right if you're fighting matt matrione
or you're fighting guys like that who
can who who
are professional football players that
can crack who are 270 pounds and
fast as [ __ ] you if you get hit with a
jab by accident you can get knocked out
so you can't make mistakes when they're
throwing bones like that with giant guys
knocked out uh derrick lewis by
sprawling he's yeah
that's right so he's strong he like shot
in and yeah he just sprawled his hips
so everything you're doing everything
you're doing the consideration is much
bigger
it's all like a head heavyweight your
head's the same size yeah
our heads are roughly the same size
might have his head a little mine's
smaller
it's you had a smaller heavyweight head
for a heavyweight kind of a problem
yeah that's a problem yeah you want to
be the ortiz got that [ __ ] but it
doesn't matter
even that he you're still getting
knocked the [ __ ] out if you're fighting
a dude his size it's 270. but i was
small i'm not 270.
oh i'm sorry okay 260. i mean i'm 255.
now all right
255. so when i was fighting i was too
like 235.
that's you were probably a little bigger
than that bubba i promise you didn't
check my wings i was 35
38 heaviest i ever was was 42. okay
i was fighting guys that's 60 65 20
pound weight difference no one wants to
talk about it
that's exactly right when you bring up
who is
we weighed in and dana you know dana was
talking i go you know he's on steroids
correct
and danny goes what i go he's got that's
who he had look at that [ __ ]
i told dan i said you know he's gonna
finish fifth in the olympia after this
oh [ __ ] what happened to his stomach
he got stabbed oh part of the game my
dad has that same skill
but now look at look at his size yeah he
does he knocked out everybody
uh-huh i mean he would just be how tall
was he
about six four yeah yeah is he black
yeah yeah
how much he weighs he's in prison 65 to
everybody there we are together
prison oops well let me see
who's he in prison for he's bigger well
he's in prison now for a domestic
violence he's a lot bigger than you are
look at how young you are holy i know
look at you
i thought that was aaron hernandez for a
second he did
240 240. and you just took him down and
held him down there
i took him down like 14 times i beat the
shot of him wasn't he that was that a
decision
he's like come on dog let's get up and
fight yeah you did not like fighting
let's get up and bang bro i'm like why
don't you learn jiu jitsu
oh he said that to you while you guys
were in the fight yeah i kept taking him
down
and then i was so worried because my
uncle pax is the first fight he went to
he uh yeah it was a big ufc on fox 5
fight
i was on fox but um i was worried about
him because
um he was part of like the mongols gang
like the biker gang and my uncle pax
that was the first fight he went to and
after the fight we all went back to the
fires hotel
so we're all at the bar you know i'm
drinking whisk or whatever and
levar comes with all his biker gangs and
i tell my brother i hit him i go hey
they're here
and all my team's like [ __ ] dude we
don't want no problems yeah and they
were all monk i don't know he's horrible
yeah
i did not know then lavar came up and
they were all great
all the biker guys were cool like man he
helped our boy with his grappling man
[Laughter]
those dudes are terrifying yeah like
that yeah
yeah they're voting by the same thing
don't don't [ __ ] with them
yeah just be responsible they're cool if
you don't [ __ ] with them yeah i don't
get why anyone has problems with them
yeah how do you have problems with those
guys
well you don't you don't go get don't go
walking around like you know
looking at my girl and just be cool